one of my favorite guests uh to appear
on this show
and um
not just because of um you know the
great conversations that we have but his
support
his support for run rich run that he
gave this year
put a lot of money in the pockets of
saint jude children's research hospital
along with the washington football team
and
the snyders as well together putting a
ton of money in the pockets of st
children's research hospital to help
sick kids get better and make sure that
parents of those kids never see a bill
he is
uh one of the best he is the head coach
of the washington football team ron
rivera how are you coach
i'm doing great rich how are you i'm
better for talking to you i can't thank
you enough for doing what you did um
i mean you know i know you you'd reached
out about uh the idea about supporting
um and then um i i wake up draft morning
and i see your video with your dog
saying you know let's run and you had
your dog run the 40 and that went viral
and it brought in so much money along
with the special donation from you you
and your wife and uh
and the snyders um i can't thank you
enough thank you
no i appreciate that but you know
richard it's something that we need to
do because we need to be aware that we
can impact a lot of lives and yeah i
have to give uh credit to my wife
stephanie though because it was her idea
you know she did all the research and
when she found out that one of the only
children proton therapy units are uh is
associated with saint jude we just knew
we had to do that
and again that's the that's the therapy
that you went through right last year
correct yes yes it is and it's it's such
a non-invasive therapy that you know it
only makes sense that the children have
it and so we just wanted to make sure we
we support it uh because we just know
how important it really is and how are
you doing how are you feeling i'm i'm
doing well rich i'm finishing up my
tenth month of uh of
uh of rehab of recuperation uh and it's
it's been going pretty well doctors have
been pleased with all my reports so far
so we'll keep our fingers crossed that
everything continues to go well if you
don't mind whatever you want to share
what does that mean your rehab i mean
what do you do how does how does that
part of your day or routine or or week
or month in any way shape or form ron
well for the most part it's truly just
recovery it's just the body you know
regenerating itself it's you know i mean
i still have to do some certain neck
exercises that continue to strengthen
the muscles around the neck that you
know that were uh you know that that
that that were at your feet from the
from the treatment um you know my
swallowing my vocal cords stuff like
that uh but it's all simple stuff and
it's all been stuff that's been you know
going well and you know while just
before we get to the football just on on
the the health and safety um aspect of
you and your team and of course our
country in this world uh what what is
the
are are you pleased is your vaccination
rate of your team better because i know
you publicly spoke about it since you
are you are at risk i mean you could not
be more at risk based on obviously the
update you just gave in your immune
system
what are are you pleased with what's
going on with your team's vaccination
raiders we're two weeks from the kickoff
of the 2021 season
i i am you know and kudos to our guys
for for
for doing the things that we need to
have them do you know um
we're we're at 90 percent you know we
still have a few other guys and they're
you know they're looking at life long
and hard so that's been a good thing for
us uh to get these guys on board um and
if we can get the the the remaining few
on board it it'll be a boon for us it
really will so i'm excited about that
well would it be a boon for how do you
view it football wise a boon football
wise not just for you personally with
your health and everyone else's but well
because again you don't want to be in
the situation where you know you might
have a couple of guys that that contact
trace or or even test positive because
now they're out they can't play and and
based on whether they get it or they
contact trace
it goes all the way back to um to um
to um
to if they get it they're out what
amounts almost two weeks and if they and
if they contact tracer out five days so
they can miss one maybe two
games even three
so uh and then just last one on this i
mean how how do you
converse with a player
or what would you say to another player
on another team
that you know won't mask up or they're
upset about being asked to even mask up
knowing that they're going to be fined
for not masking up that's what's going
on in the nfl that's kind of a big story
today what do you say on that front ron
um
i think it's kind of silly not to not to
do something that's been you know that's
been checked on that's been vetted um
that's been um
that's been um
um okayed uh by the uh by the fda first
of all and then secondly it's uh it's
something that's been um you know that
that that that's been approved and and
so many times you know there are some
things that haven't been approved by the
fda that we we we do um you know my
understanding is uh tattoo inc is not um
is not fda approved and it's not
regulated so you know
what his you know i'm saying i mean
let's think about what we're doing does
this make sense
so yeah we just yeah i just tried to
give examples of why they should and
it's it seems to have worked you're at
90 percent on the washington football
team right now going into the season yes
okay yes very very pleased with what
what what we've gotten our guys to to
to do um and again
um we're not trying to force anybody
we're asking you know you say hey look
can you would you consider this think
about this you know this this affects
all of us
you know and and so for the most part i
think the guys have been pretty
receptive you know we're we're trying
not to put you know undue pressure we're
just trying to inform and give them
options
ron rivera here on the rich eisen show
okay ron you you got your team's feet
wet wet your beak a little bit in the
playoffs
last year how will that experience do
you think fuel what what could be for
the washington football team in 2021
well i think it bodes well for us but
but rich my concern coming in the
training camp was you know it was our
was our maturity level as a team you
know we're very young football team the
one thing i didn't want our guys think
is that we've arrived you know just
because we we we we played well down the
stretch just because we got in the
playoffs
it doesn't mean you know that we're
automatically in again we're gonna have
to earn it and that's the thing they
have to understand
so um you know i don't want i don't want
our guys approaching this season go well
you know we've arrived no we haven't we
haven't arrived we're still working
we're still learning we're still growing
that's what i want that's what i'm
concerned about is that something
fitzpatrick can lead the charge on as a
guy who's been there done that gotten so
many opportunities and is it just seems
like this one could be his most golden
yet ron to be honest absolutely i agree
with that and and that's why having a
veteran guy like that on the team is so
important because he can speak to those
things he can point those things out he
can get people to understand you know
just hey you have to earn it every day
it's just not i'm showing up and things
are and things are good to go
how does he lead on that front what can
you give me an example of watching him
do just that well
what i really appreciate is is is as we
practice the way he practices the way he
does things you know um
we had a great example uh uh demi brown
was running around
and fits through the ball just to his
side and the enemy had had a stretch out
to make the catch and when diamond came
to the to the sideline you know 50 went
up to him and said hey listen now on
that certain type of situation i'm gonna
throw away from your leverage so just
understand if your leverage is on this
side i'm going to throw you over here to
get you away from it that way you can
catch it in stride so a little bit you
know few players later in practice
uh the emmy went out ran the same route
did the same move and sure enough 50 let
him perfectly and and and he caught the
ball in full stride and what would have
been probably a five or six yard game
turned into a 15-yard explosive play and
he comes to the sideline you could see
the smile on the kid's face and all 50
did was look at him and give him a
thumbs up and you could tell that the
kid's going man that's cool
i mean that that to me that's leadership
and and that's what you're hoping that
you get from your veteran guys i just
think you know you you know how much of
a journeyman he has been and that's a
phrase that is definitely infused with a
negativity because that means a team
decides not to keep or a team thinks
somebody else can do better or a team
like last year decides to replace with a
young quarterback
right but
you've been around quarterbacks that
have won super bowls and you've been
around quarterbacks that have taken a
team of yours to the super bowl do you
think ryan fitzpatrick
has that ability ron rivera to do that i
think ryan professor can most certainly
lead us and will he get to the super
bowl well that's what we're about to
find out um but i do know this he's got
the right kind of makeup you know he
knows how to manage a game he knows how
to direct a a a an offensive charge he
knows how to get a team energized
and that's what we're looking for we're
only for a guy to come in and dominately
take over game all by himself we're
looking about it we're looking for a guy
that can manage our football
manager game and when he has to make a
play he's there to make a player two for
us that's what i believe he can do for
us and how will the offense look
different i mean this guy as we also
know um as opposed to last year when you
had um
you know
a a raw quarterback out there in dwayne
haskins and then a veteran in alex smith
was coming back from a catastrophic
injury we all know that ryan fitzpatrick
sometimes sees windows that he shouldn't
throw into and says screw it right and
he just he's got that risking mentality
here and then you got some burners how
how different will this offense look
this year as opposed to
last and then previous ones of yours ron
well i i think this dolphins have the
chance to be
uh to be just as dynamic as as i've been
associated with because of that you know
because of that speed it's one of the
things that we went out and wanted to do
on purpose we we went out with the
thought process and the idea of getting
faster you know that's why we drafted
the amy brown that's that's why we find
curtis saying you know that's why we
brought in william jackson to play
corner for us you know um we wanted to
get faster across the board as a
football team and a couple more minutes
left with you ron um
chase young how's he better how's he
already better
oh man i'll tell you you've watched him
really work on certain aspects of his
game that that you know he probably took
for granted when he was in college but
now because of the the pros that he's
facing he has to be so much better and
so now you see him he's worked on
certain aspects of his game that that
that weren't as sharp as they were or
needed to be last year so now you watch
him and he does some things that are
different his counters are different his
timing is different uh coming off the
ball is explosive ability is there and
he's been working on that and that's
something that i think can really help
him grow as he goes forward okay last
one for you um
what what's the where's the the team
nickname front i know again you got
you know rosters you got to build and
teams you got to coach but you're also
an integral part of that front office
where where are we on the
the new team nickname scenario well it's
come down to three finalists i know that
okay um they had they brought me in
asked me my opinion on on on the uh
there was a news like six finalists yes
uh what i thought about them i gave them
what i thought was the order um i do
know i sat down went through as far as
the the color schemes that they're
saying the same but how they're gonna
use them on the new uniforms okay uh and
then the last thing last part obviously
is to decide on the name and to put the
logo together and everything so that's
kind of cool i know that's coming um and
we'll see i'm excited about it okay so
you have given
a ron rivera preference you have given a
check mark to one over the others you
have done that okay
all right um and is it possible that
they stick with the current name it's
just gonna still be washington football
team is that well i know that i know
that is something that is a
consideration
but we'll see i mean you know mr snyder
uh mrs snyder and working with jason
wright they'll come they'll come to a uh
conclusion is it too late to put in the
eisen shows as a possibility is the door
already shut is it two i know i might be
late to the party my timing may be off
timing's everything it's too late
just a little late to the party okay the
washington eyes and shows the wesses the
wes is just that's
too late
well i can't you you're right you know
what you miss a hundred percent of the
shots you don't take ron right yep
you're right you're right well i'm glad
to hear you in good spirits and in good
health and have a great season start and
let's chat down the line ron appreciate
the time cool i appreciate it thank you
right back at you that's ron rivera at
riverboat run hc on twitter right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here